What's up, Marvel fans?
We're here with Jon Watts,
the director, and family.
So Jon is an incredibly
incredible director.
We've seen two Spider-Man
movies already.
What makes him so amazing?
That's a tip.
Uh.
Well, he's our brother.
He's our baby brother.
Yeah, he's our baby brother.
I wanted to bring my
family on the red carpet.
just because, historically,
Spider-Man's out
there helping regular people.
That's what he does.
And my family
literally does that.
My brother is a firefighter,
my sister's a nurse,
my other sister
here is a teacher.
And they're like
actually out there
on the front lines
legitimately helping
people over this past
terrible year and a half.
So I just wanted to sort of take
a little bit of the spotlight
off of me and shine it on them
and all the people that have
been doing great things to
help people in this really
tough couple of years.
That's amazing.
That's incredible.
That's your answer.
That's the answer.
So Jon just spoke about
how you inspire him,
how does he inspire you?
Oh my goodness.
I bring them to
red carpet events.
[LAUGHTER]
They get to meet Tom
Holland and Zendaya.
Now, this is a
huge, huge film.
Where did you even begin?
Well, at the end
of the last movie,
we kind of gave ourselves
a really big ending where
we revealed Peter's identity.
So we started there.
Straight to the
point, I love it.
Now, super villains
from previous Spider-Man
movies are in this film.
He's just like standing here.
This is really fun.
Well, what was it like
to be a part of that?
Oh, it was great.
I mean, I'm a fan
of those movies.
So to have them there,
I was just being
a nerd like everyone else.
[MUSIC PLAYING]